wie viele leute haben sie denn heute
gegen korona impfen können ich habe 18
leute gehen und sind sie überrannt
worden im vorfeld oder was weiß ich habe
über ich hatte am donnerstag angekündigt
dass ich bayern tag impfstoff bekommen
am dienstag und ich habe mehrere hundert
anmeldungen
herr doktor ist man bei ihnen hat das
nicht ganz so einfach angefangen denn
dort gab es jetzt schon probleme mit dem
impfstoff zumindest haben sie heute
keinen bekommen richtig was war da los
also muss sagen wir haben den impfstoff
gerade vor etwa einer stunde gekriegt
gott sei dank ich weiß auch von anderen
kollegen wie das nicht bekommen haben
und ich muss da der kollegin
beipflichten wir sind wirklich überrannt
worden
heute morgen ging das schon los
beziehungsweise am wochenende mit
telefonaten usw also wirklich bahn sind
heute war wirklich ein ganz
schrecklicher tag
dazu muss man aber auch sagen wir werden
morgen damit starten wir haben auch
schon die liste gerade patienten die ich
im und rp haben oder die ok schnitts
gegeben sind
das sind die ds priorisiert sind bei uns
man muss natürlich so sagen wir haben
auch teilweise patienten da hat die
haben schon für nächste woche nimmt
stellen ihnen sagen aber weil es bei
ihnen so schön ist ein bequemer möchte
mir lieber bei ihnen eine geben sperren
das kann man natürlich nicht machen
gerade wenn das so ist dass der eben
stoppt so knapp ist dann sollten jede
chance in dem was zu machen
aber was ich besonders frustrierend war
und sich heute beim einen dönerladen des
vertrauens war und mich mit dem ein
bisschen aus gold hat bei den besitzer
dass der keim kommt sagte wissen sie
erstmal wir kommen aus ganz ost
anatolien seinem kleinen dorf 60
kilometer von der nächsten stadt die
sind schon alle durchgehen
und da kann ich nur sagen es kann doch
nicht sein also dass wir gegen nord
mazedonien von ihr okay geschenkt aber
dass wir jetzt dagegen so schön also das
bin ich wirklich ziemlich schlecht
mehr nachrichten und breaking news nur
bei bate schau dich hier das nächste
video an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren